[Musique]
c'est l'heure du conte surtout le moment
de démontrer ses prouesses en français
une cafop liam et anglophones mais il
termine sa deuxième année dans une école
de langue française
il semble de plus en plus à l'aise dans
la langue de molière
son père ken qui a pourtant fréquenté un
programme d'immersion jusqu'à l'âge de
12 ans à plus de difficultés à suivre le
fil de l'histoire
le français de monfils sera bientôt
meilleur que le mien dit il c'est qu
après l'immersion kane qui a grandi qui
habite à calgary a eu peu d'occasions de
s'exercer au jeu propre mais l'immersion
peut aussi mener au bilinguisme à l'aja
dieu il pas besoin d'aller chercher bien
loin pour trouver des exemples
kelly gordon la soeur de kent habite
maintenant montréal où elle est
professeur en sciences politiques à
l'université mcgill
j'ai beaucoup d'amis francophone j'avais
tout un quartier franco part aussi am je
suis un grand joueur
alors je joue au tennis en france je
suis quand même sur une équipe avec les
francophones à pujaut des comme force en
france et selon elle la fréquentation
d'une école d'immersion ou primaire et
au secondaire en alberta a fait toute la
différence
si j'ai pas fai l'immersion je serais
pas capable de prendre en france est
comme ça mais entre kelly etienne quelle
expérience et la plus représentative
si les premières classes d'immersion
comme celles ci ont ouvert leurs portes
dans les années 60 il existe encore peu
de données sur l'impact de ces
programmes
une étude récente de statistique canada
montrent toutefois qu'à l'extérieur du
québec
parmi les jeunes anglophones qui se
disait bilingue à 14 17 ans 50% d'entre
eux est plus capable de soutenir une
conversation en français
dix ans plus tard et même si près d'un
demi million d'élèves fréquentent les
écoles d'immersion chaque année au
canada le taux de bilinguisme chez les
anglophones hors québec
stan hier 7 % depuis trois décennies
pourquoi on a encore nos fans qui
parlent pas couramment ou ce qui prime
pas facilement en france à ce niveau là
pas été suffisant robert asselin est un
ancien conseiller du gouvernement
trudeau a aussi travaillé avec stéphane
guillon dont dossier des langues
officielles
l'immersion il y a cru au départ mais il
pense aujourd'hui qu'il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin si on veut augmenter
les taux de bilinguisme faudrait au
moins que tous les anglophones et passé
un an au québec alors que parce que les
enfants lorsqu'ils sont dans le version
la ministre jolie reconnaît qu'un des
gros défis l'immersion c'est la
rétention après la fin du cursus
le problème c'est une fois rendu au
collège à l'université ce qui continue
et même rang des adultes est ce qu'ils
ne continuent pas la da'wa souhaite
d'ailleurs augmenter la présence du
français dans les entreprises sous
juridiction fédérale comme les banques
et les compagnies de télécommunications
et pour robert à cela il faut créer un
mouvement plus large où les anglophones
ont envie d'apprendre la langue parce
qu'ils sont attachés à la culture
francophone
je pense que ça peut donner ne serait
pas l'échec mais la partie manquante de
l'immersion je pense que comme robert
qu'il y crois surtout qu'il ne faut pas
voir l'immersion comme une fin en soi si
l'intention ces deux îles reconnaître
que ces programmes ont quand même de la
valeur
même s'ils ne mènent pas un bilinguisme
parfait j'espère tout de même que son
fils pourra poursuivre sur sa lancée en
français à l'âge adulte